okay so this talks called hacking humans
social engineering and techniques for
how to protect against them so it's not
an overly technical talk so you can sort
of relax a bit there's no complex Maps
or coding involved so loose agenda of
what I'm gonna go through this afternoon
so we can talk a bit about what social
engineering actually is then we're going
to talk about some famous social
engineering cases there's some examples
there we're going to go through social
engineering techniques and sort of a
rough high-level framework which
attackers go through when they try to
amount an attack and then we're gonna
talk about how to protect yourselves and
your company against social engineers
which is the important part and then
I've got a few interesting resources to
share with you at the end so quick
disclaimer first I'm sure that it to say
it but you know I'll say it anyway
social engineering generally leads to
bad and illegal things so that's the
whole point of the talk isn't so teach
you how to do illegal things it's to
teach you how to protect yourself from
it because you don't to end up like this
guy so social engineering is a huge huge
subject so you know we can't do the
entire thing justice in an hour I mean
some people spend their lives studying
this stuff it's all psychology and all
that good stuff but what we're gonna do
is we're gonna treat it as an art of the
possible so it gives you the the basic
grounding is what social engineering is
and the steps that you go through to do
it and then you know if you're
interested in the subjects I've got some
good resources and books at the end
which you can follow up with so first of
all a start off with a little story a
little fireside story so we've got a guy
called Keith who's sitting there late at
night working in tech supports they
dreaming about his tea break week and a
Goan oneis game of pool with his friend
and it suddenly he gets a phone call so
he picks it up and goes hello this is
Keith from technical support how can I
help you and there's a panics voice on
the end of the phone
Keith it's Tom senior financial VP from
floor 9 I've got a big meeting tomorrow
and I can't get into my system to access
the powerpoints and spreadsheets if I
can't access e systems then you know I'm
screwed we've got a massive investor
meeting in the morning so Tom's like eh
well have you gone through the password
reset process well of course I've gone
through why do you think I'm phoning you
it keeps on locking out and I go through
it and he's starting to get quite irate
and so upset
at this point so after a bit of Turing
I'm throwing sort of Keith decides okay
well I'll do a password reset for you
now and we'll get you back into the
system you know you're an executive I
don't want to I don't want to piss you
off so say so time I know well what do
me to change your password to and he
goes I will change it to monkey 25 made
up on the spot so Keith does that and
then Tom tries to try to password and in
sudden he's in - oh my god thank you
very much because of you I'm now going
to be able to do this meeting tomorrow
so you have just saved this massive
investment meeting thank you and he
hangs up
it's a keep sitting there you know he's
very happy with himself you know he's
daydreaming about running down the
corridor high-fiving all his friends
because he's now just helped to senior
exec on the floor nine and you know this
exact now knows who Keith is so great
done a bit of networking as well so what
keeps doing this Tom who's not actually
a senior VP in the company is actually a
hacker is copy and lots of documents off
the network onto a USB stick and then he
leaves to build him it's a very simple
example but you said you know a typical
type of thing that can happen in a
corporate environment and I've worked in
some banks in the UK where these sorts
of things have happens in technical
support okay so what is social
engineering so I went to my good friend
Wikipedia for a definition and it's the
act of influencing someone to take an
action that may not be in their best
interest so it's getting people to do
something that's not good for them
so there's three different types of kind
of social engineering attacks out there
so the one that we're all probably
familiar with is phishing where we get
those really annoying emails from people
we know we've got rich relatives in some
African country or you've got an email
trying to get you to log on to your bank
account we've very convincing Bank log
on page second type is phishing which is
where you get people phoning you up so
you know the typical call center phone
calls you get then you get them over
here where it's a call from Microsoft
suppose aleena detected a virus on your
system and they want to get access to
your system to help you out that's a
fishing attack and the next one is
impersonation which is where someone's
taking on a persona of someone else
which is kind of what we're going to
focus on in this talk
so a few stats so there's a link at the
bottom there from social engineer dot
org and I got some pretty good stats on
there most of them are us-based but it
kind of illustrates the point so 90% of
all the email is spam I think we all
know that when we look at our inboxes
every day and phishing represents 77% of
all social based attacks so it's still
one of the most popular types of attacks
out there because it's so easy to do at
scale and clicking links in emails
accounted for 88 percent of all reported
phishing so that's like your typical you
know click on this link to reset your
bank account password go so a very
convincing page it's looking identical
to your bank but is actually an imposter
sites so phishing
so in 2012 in the u.s. there's two point
four million customers targeted for
phone fraud but then in just in the
first half of 2013 its 2.3 million
customers so you can see how it is you
know exponentially growing in severity
and to large corporations the average
loss per accounts can equal around four
to two and a half thousand dollars so
you can have a massive impact on
companies if I say a bank account gets
compromised
it's an impersonation so typical
touching a personation you know like
medical ID theft is very good one my
people steal your medical data and use
that to build up a persona of who you
are because medical data is very private
so therefore is generally quite trusted
information and typically the top place
Ryder theft is in the workplace so you
know your companies may spend hundreds
of thousands of dollars on firewalls and
intrusion protection systems which is
all well and good and you know it should
be done but the weakest link in your
company is gonna be the people working
for it and 80 percent of thefts involve
disabling or bypassing control so we saw
that in the in the story at the
beginning caved the technical support
engineer sort of bypass that control and
did a password reset without really
doing too much checking so he makes up
social engineers so you know typically
we have hackers they're the ones we all
know about penetration testers are
people who are legitimately paid by
companies to try and break into their
systems and I'll either do that via
traditional hacking or via
trying to impersonate people and extract
information like passwords from people
then you've got your typical things that
spies and governments you know the all
the sorts of things that we see in James
Bond films where you know this Spy takes
on a personality or a persona of someone
else a disgruntled employees recruiters
are very good ones are trying to
manipulate you to do something that's
not necessarily in your best interest I
get about ten of those calls a day and
sales people cuz they're trying to get
you to buy something which you maybe
don't need but they're gonna try and get
it to buy anyway it's all a form of
social engineering okay anyone think of
who the best type of social engineers
are there's not on the list actors are
so good right I was going to say
children especially my daughter she can
pretty much get me to do anything I'm
sure and there's a lot people nodding so
it's similar similar situation so why
social engineering well it consistently
works
people are very easy to manipulate and
as we'll see later people generally want
to be nice and be be helpful and people
use that to their advantage as we've
said before people are the biggest
vulnerability of any network so if you
haven't gone through any of the
mitigation techniques which we're going
to talk about later you know it doesn't
matter how much you spend on expensive
hardware to protect your network
actually someone's just gonna go in and
copy files off onto a USB stick and take
them out the building and that's a
problem and also it's a path of least
resistance so if you're trying to get
past where it's whacks a system you know
you could do it the traditional way and
try and do a data breach and get the
password files and then brute force and
that's that's a lot of work to try and
extract a password or you can just
manipulate someone and get them to to
tell you it so some typical examples of
a social engineering attack so customer
services you know they're people on the
front line of the company on the phones
you know all it takes is you to do you
know five or so phone calls to different
people extracting different bits of
information every time to help build up
a larger picture which will then allow
you to go in and sort of do your main
attack
delivery staff is another big problem I
mean if someone turns up in a brown
boiler suit carrying a load of packages
generally companies tend to let them in
and if you don't ask or them around the
building then you've just given someone
access to the building quite easily so
generally any type of phone call where
you're going to get someone on the phone
is a very good way of getting
information because they can't see you
so it's a very one-sided type of
interaction and as we've seen in our
example technical support is a great way
of trying to get information on a system
especially if you target junior members
of staff for a fresh out of college or
university who that you aren't very
experienced in these things they're
going to be very eager to help so I've
got a few sort of famous software
engineering cases just so we can see you
know where people have done this and
ultimately paid the price of going to
prison so as anyone heard of kevin
Mitnick you know a very famous guy now
so he used to be quite dodgy in his
younger years so he had a high profile
arrest in 1995 and he spent five years
in prison and he's done loads of hacks
from the you know from the 1979 onwards
so many as 16 he broke into debt
computers and he was sort of pirating
software off of their servers and he's
done things I occurred right in the bus
network in LA for free by hacking the
payment systems and he's in the end he
was charged with 14 counts of fraud and
eight cases of unauthorized entry of
course these days he's a reformed
character so he's now a successful
security consultant and he spends most
of his time teaching companies how to
protect themselves and people like him
so he's actually made a very good career
off the back of it but yet to spend
quite he is in prison to do that those
are some books that he's written highly
recommend them I'll show you that I'll
show them again at the end of the
presentation the first two so the art of
intrusion in the art of deception are
probably some of the best books I've
ever read on the subject and then ghost
in the wires he's kind of his biography
is a fascinating read I read him on
holiday once to my wife's horror we
didn't technical books on holiday
so next one is a guy called Frank
Abagnale he said on her do this go yep
so he was a yep can you see my next
slide but yeah you're right the film
catch me if you can so he was a
confidence trickster and cheque forger
and imposter so he did all sorts of
things like taking on different
identities to become an airline pilot
doctors lawyers all that sort of thing
he's very very convincing and even
managed to escape custody twice he's
quite slippery trap as well but as a guy
at the front side here there's a film
with Leonardo DiCaprio and Tom Hanks
called catch me if you can which is kind
of a Hollywood dramatization of his life
it's a brilliant film he's not saying it
another level so snippet from the film
there where he's taken on the persona of
an airline pilots which is quite
frightening to think that someone who's
not actually a pilot is helping to fly
your plane I'll bear that in mind when I
do my 30 hour journey back to the UK so
final example when we look at his
Charles Ponzi so everyone's probably
heard of the Ponzi scheme or the pyramid
scheme and this is a mail fraud scheme
using an international reply coupon so
you buy the reply coupons and then you
can sell them for stamps and he
generally get more money when he sold
them than what you cost to buy them so
he started doing this but then he sort
of turned it into a pyramid scheme he
had lots of people invested money so he
could use that money to buy more of a
pie coupons overseas and he still
carried on building up this this ruse
until it all eventually sort of
collapsed and then he cannot remember
how long you spent in prison but I mean
he I think he made it out of life okay
so it's because of social engineering
techniques eschaton czar sort of the the
process of how it's done so it's
generally broken down into four stages
through about information gathering
pretexting elicitation and manipulation
so we'll go through each of those in
turn so to do a social engineer attack
it takes a lot of preparation so you're
not just going to target someone and say
you're an associate engineer you and
expect to be successful at it because
you won't you'll probably fail so you
need to gather as much information as
you can from different sources and
there's various different ways of doing
it and one of the easiest ways of doing
it is this fishing for
bins or dumpster diving as they call it
so you're literally looking for any bits
of information or paper that's been
thrown out at a company or someone's
home so bank statements if you don't
shred them you just throw them away
there's a goldmine of information now
prescriptions you know for medication is
very useful something you can find out
information if I've got any particularly
illnesses which you can use to your
advantage and so pretty much anything
about that I mean another example as
well is if you go through someone's bins
and it's full of whiskey bottles and you
can probably guess that they've got an
alcohol problem so you know getting them
down the pub might be a good way to do
it social engineering attack against
them this day and age is you can use
lots of social networks this is called
open source intelligence Oh since they
call it where you're using public-facing
sites try and extract information so not
everyone has their Facebook profile lock
down some people have so have a lot of
information on there that's public the
same again with Twitter so you can look
at the sorts of things that people are
tweeting and build up quite a good
picture around someone's personality and
Linkedin is an absolute goldmine because
you generally put your entire career
history on them so you can get lots of
information from that but also you're
just doing a good old-fashioned Google
or a Bing search I'll put that on there
to balance it out but generally Google
so another good way of stealing
information is by using malware to
install key loggers on people's systems
so you know if you want to get someone's
password why not just record the
keystrokes that they're typing in on
their terminal another popular one as
well is malware which takes regular
screenshots from your system and then
post them off to a service if you've got
confidential information on your screen
then you can have this malware just
taking image dumps from the screen
compressing them then sending them off
to a server which is why you should
always run anti-malware software loved
one is shoulder surfing again very
common so if you sit in there and you
just look over look over someone's
shoulder and I was on the train commute
to work on the train sort of stood up
and I could see someone typing on their
email you know you just look over and
you can see exactly what they're typing
in this case someone was writing their
message to her husband it's very easy to
do it just up and looked so you have to
be very aware of what you're doing so if
you're doing something this company for
then you're on a train just imagine you
know the amount of people that could be
looking over your shoulder and seeing
what you're doing or if you're in your
bank balance in a public place
that's all things need to be aware of
there are ways to help protect yourself
akin to shoulder surfing and these days
actually these actually exist they're
called privacy scuffs when I found the
photo I was intrigued and there is
actually companies that sell these they
look like a bit of an idiot using it
good or good on a hot winter's day
though you know in Sydney okay so the
next station is pretexted and so this is
the practice of presenting oneself as
someone else in order to obtain private
information so it's acting it's taking
on someone else's persona and so general
principles that you want to follow when
you're doing pretexting so the more
planning and research you do against
persona your take on it's gonna lead to
more success so as I said you're not
just gonna target someone and then go
straight him in for the kill as it were
you're gonna put a lot of preparation in
and try and work out what your new
identity is going to be shared interests
makes success more likely so if you're a
fan of Manchester United Football Club
yeah and you know and you know you're
rare you know your target is as well
then it gives you a shared interest so
we need to start trying to manipulate
them you can just spend a lot of time
talking about shared interest to help
build up a rapport with that person so
you don't necessarily go straight in for
the kill you might spend weeks building
up a friendship someone good acting
definitely helps so you know you need to
look convincing when you're doing it so
it is no different
acting in a play you are taking on kind
of a real world acting role another
principle is always keeping it simple so
try not to over complicate the persona
that you're taking on because more
complicated you make it the easier it is
going to be to fail and sort of screw up
they ought to try and use information it
doesn't need any verification as well so
if you say something that the person
maybe finds a bit suspect and then
they're going to go off and then try and
verify that information if you've made a
mistake and that's going to help unravel
your persona
so you're in a mini planning a pretext
in the stage you know you need to define
what it is you're actually trying to
achieve goes without saying with
anything you know good planning always
leads to more success and you need to
plan for different reactions or stray
off the happy path so if all goes well
you're going to go in and do your
pretexting attack against on one if it
all goes well you'll get to the result
that you want but what if it doesn't go
well what are all the different failure
cases that can happen you need to
prepare for those so if you're trying to
say take on a persona of someone who's
single not in a relationship and then
you accidentally turn up and you've got
your wedding ring on and they notice you
know what would you do in that situation
and we'll just being friendly be
sufficient I mean do you need to go to
all the efforts of taking on this big
big acting persona could just being nice
to someone be what you need to do it
could be just as simple as that this is
another sort of definition of social
engineering so it's a clever
manipulation of the natural human
tendency to trust and the key word there
is trust those building up trust with
another person okay so we've talked
about pretexting which is about you know
building up the persona over the person
that you're trying to be so the next
step is elicitation and this is the act
of getting information without directly
asking for it so now if I go out to you
to say can you tell me your password No
so you're trying to get someone to give
you information without directly giving
it up without directly asking for it so
elicitation is all about trying to
exploit human nature so most people want
to be polite you know not everyone but
generally most people are nice want to
be helpful especially your conference
like this you know people are generally
very nice and want to help and people
want to appear well-informed as well so
nobody wants to be the guy or the girl
he doesn't know the answer to something
he makes you look a bit stupid so people
so if you ask the right questions and it
makes people feel like they're being
informed and being the person with all
of knowledge and people might generally
be a bit more loose lips and sort of
tell you stuff that they're not supposed
to you just to make themselves look and
feel better
people want to be appreciated as well so
if you're as part of your persona if
you're being very nice and appeased
sooo you know thanking them you know
maybe buy them a drink for helping you
out with something you know people like
to be appreciated yeah bit of a pat on
the back and generally honest people
don't like to have hold information or
life so if you're a good honest person
then you know lying isn't in your in
your nature so you're gonna be very
truthful in the information that you
give up the best way to succeed at this
then is really understanding how to
communicate with people so this is why
you know I say it's very easy for us to
talk about it now for an hour but
actually this some of this stuff can
take years and years to master because
it's all about human psychology and you
need to be able to adapt communications
to fit the situation so it's a bit like
what we're saying before about trying to
cater for the the failure paths in your
pretexting you need to change your
communication style to fit the situation
so if someone starts getting a bit
aggressive towards you because you're
going in too strong you need to be able
to adapt your style of communication to
dial it back a bit and you want to build
a bond with your target so you're not
just going to go straight in directly
and try and get the information out with
someone you might spend a long period of
time friending them so you might meet
them down the pub build up a friendship
over several weeks or months and then
you try and get the information that you
want so you don't try to see don't
arouse any suspicion no see this goes
without saying that whenever you're with
that person you have to stay in
character so if you go out of character
or they see you going out of character
when you're on the phone or if they see
you around locally then that's not gonna
that's not going to help you but also
you need to know how to use effective
questioning techniques so we'll look at
some of these now so four main
questioning techniques are out there so
we've got neutral open closed and
leading so a neutral question doesn't
directly targets the person on how to
answer the question so you're not
leading or direct in there anyway so if
you say how do you like the way for
today that kind of invites you to say as
much as you want then you've got
open-ended questions which encourages a
full meaningful answer using the
subjects own knowledge so tell me about
the relationship of your father it's a
very open question
can go into as much detail as you want
or how do you feel about the election
candidates you know it gives you the
opportunity to be a lot more open in how
you answer the question but then on the
flip side of that we have closed
questions so you know do you get some of
your father yes or no you know it
doesn't really invite you to say much
more because it's very directed in how
it's they're being asked and then who
are you going to vote for you know Trump
or Hillary okay to the American election
it doesn't really invite you to say much
more
then we've got leading questions so
these are more open in nature but you're
trying to lead the person down a
particular way of answering the question
so the example on the screen there so do
you have any problems with your boss
it's kind of implying the you might have
some problems with your boss and then
that might kind of coerce your answer a
little bit or how fast was the red car
going when it smashed into the blue car
so you're kind of putting the idea into
the person's head that was actually the
red car that was going fast and it was
at fault and it might not have been but
you're trying to lead them into a
particular way of answering so know me
when you're doing this and you want to
try and funnel the question so you'll
start off very neutral and oh very
neutral then you'll go into a more open
style and as you start to get towards
the information that you're trying to
get from the subject you'll then start
going a lot more close and if necessary
you'll use more directed questions so
you think of it as a funnel okay so
we've covered protection elicitation so
pretexting is taking on a persona and
elicitation is using that persona to
extract information but what's the
difference between manipulation and
influencing so very there's very subtle
differences between them so influency
needs about getting someone to change
their mind in a way that is good for
them so in the case of the party last
night if you're considering having that
third whisky and your friend says I
think you should do that because you're
supposed to be up early you've got to
talk at nine o'clock know they're trying
to influence you in a way that's good
for you by helping you but it's
manipulation is influencing someone to
change their mind in a way that it's not
good for them so in the case of the
story at the beginning you know the
person who is calling the
the technical support line was directly
trying to manipulate the person on the
phone so it wasn't a way that was good
for them it's very bad for them in the
end
so influencing generally ends up in a
win-win situation so it's a win for you
and it's a win for the person that
you're influencing whereas manipulation
is generally a win-lose scenario I think
it's without saying the manipulation is
generally bad but for social engineering
it's good it's kind of the Hult the
whole point of is you try to manipulate
someone so if we go back to our original
definition from the beginning of the
talk what we said it's an acts of
influencing someone to take an action
that may not be in their best interest
actually we're talking about
manipulation okay so what are some
typical manipulation techniques so fear
is a typical technique or the what's
called the fear there Mele technique so
you make someone scared about something
and then you offer them instant relief
to take that fear away so example here
so hi this is technical support we've
detected a virus on your machine and
it's gonna lock all your files oh [ __ ]
I'm gonna lose all my files so fear
starts to set in we need to install a
virus killer but if you give us the
password to your machine will log on and
we'll put the virus checker on there and
everything could be good so that's the
relief so you get that you get the
person into a soar heightened state of
fear and then you offer immediate relief
except they trust you guilt is another
way use guilt as a way of making someone
comply so you do someone a favor and
then use it against them later
so blackmail here's a very typical
technique here so example I need you to
copy these files for me you I mean you
owe me a favor
after I kept ex a secret for you earlier
you know he's guilt tripping someone
into doing something for you another
technique so the foot in the door
technique so asking the victim to do a
very small request first gets you get to
the foot in the door then once they
comply you can then follow on and get
more information out of them so very
common technique used by salespeople so
if you get door-to-door salesmen at your
door they might ask you a question like
you know howsoever you know you give
them a give them a response but by
getting that posit
response from that person in in the
first place yeah actually makes it a lot
easier for them so then start up a
conversation with you so one day you
know can you tell me the time can you
spare some change
typical like questions you used to lead
in with someone so those are the the
main stages you go through for mounting
a social engineering attack I say that's
it's quite a high level framework you
can spend a lot of time going into the
psychological intricacies of it but what
we really want to know is how can we
protect ourselves from this so we're
going to go through some techniques that
we can use for personal mitigation for
yourselves but then also what you want
your companies to be doing so if your
companies aren't doing any of these
things even maybe you can go back to
your office's next where you can try and
get them to change so as you said then
common targets in a company tend to be
junior staff because they're very eager
to to please and help contractors also
very common people to be targeted
because they don't have the same sort of
vested interest in the company as what
full time member of staff does and I've
worked with various companies before and
all contractors are from outsourcing
operations as well we're culturally from
the countries they're from they're very
eager to try and help because they don't
want to be seen as evasive or not
helpful
so they're very good people to target
admin staff as well and support staff
again people that are popping more
junior in the company so if you go in
pretending to be an executive and you're
trying to get information out of them
they're gonna they're gonna want to help
so they're very easy to try and target
whereas if you try and go against
someone who's higher up in the company
they're probably gonna be a bit more
savvy and not as easily when it provides
a manipulatable
so if you've got someone phoning you up
or turning up at the office the best
things to do start with his awesome
Friday very simple can you show me your
ID you know if a guy turns up wearing a
brown boiler suit carrying a load of
parcels you know are you just gonna let
him in or you gonna check his
credentials first is he from DHL is he
from Easi from Bob's Delivery Service
you need to check
and watching for any other character
questions as well so again going back to
the delivery man example if he turns up
and then he starts asking about where
the server room is or things that are
out of very out of character for a
delivery man and that should be an
immediate red flag again a lot of these
of a kind of common sense which would be
clear to know so don't let guests roam
free and a building so again
delivery man if he turns up and he has
to personally deliver a parcel to
someone and you check these credentials
and you think they're okay then go with
him make sure he's escorted or get
someone else to escort him don't just
let them sort wander off around the
building this one again should be
obvious especially to our technical folk
but it isn't obvious to everyone don't
plug in a thumb drives that you find
lying on the floor so you know very
common scenarios you might see a you
know a 16 gig thumb drive on the floor
you'll pick it off Nakul 16 gig that's
quite a good one yeah they're not
they're not cheap and you might go and
plug it in into your laptop and then
that could be where key loggers get
installed or or worse so when you're out
and about and you're gonna the
organization just be be aware of what
you're saying so you know pubs and bars
are very bad for this once you've had a
few drinks and you out with your
colleagues you tend to start being a bit
looser with the the type of conversation
you have in so you might start talking
about projects you're working on at the
company or you might start taking the
piss out of your boss I'm sure
everyone's really professional it
doesn't actually do that but you never
know who's around you listening yeah all
it needs is someone who's deliberately
targeting your company to be sitting on
the next table listening in it was an
image to do anything you're just giving
them loads of information to help them
build up their pretext so shredding
documents is very important so when you
finish with your bank statements at home
don't just fling them in the bin you
know buy one those small portable
shredders and shred them first because
only if anyone is going for you rubbish
trying to find the information you just
made their life instantly harder by
shredding everything so prescriptions
bank statements letters anything
again going back to fun drive but don't
store really important sensitive
documents on thumb drives because
they're very easy to lose they fall out
of your pocket or you leave them on a
train or if you do have to use thumb
drives to store documents make sure
they're encrypted with a strong password
don't write the password on the side of
the USB thumb drive
I see I seen someone do that before it's
hilarious so if you're using company
laptops they should all have Drive
encryption on them you know laptops are
very easy to steal probably not as easy
to lose but people do lose them but you
know if someone steals you yeah laptop
make sure you've got encryption on it
you know max for example come with
encrypted drives by default I think
Windows 10 does now does it
what do you have to enable it I thought
you might use Windows for a while but
make sure you using some kind of full
disk encryption larger corporations
Germany mandate this as well especially
in regulated environments they have full
disk encryption again be aware of who's
looking over your shoulder you know you
could be sitting on on the train or the
bus working on some documents for work
that you need to get done for tomorrow
but do you know who's sitting behind you
and looking at your screen or sitting
next to you maybe if you've got
important sales figures or source code
or anything on your screen you think he
you know you're being good by working on
the train batchi anyone could be looking
at what you're doing and a final one for
personal mitigation techniques saying is
educate yourself you know by going to
talks like this reading some of the book
resources I'm going to put up at the end
he's you know there's lots of really
good stuff on YouTube as well about
social engineering which is very
insightful and as well as resources like
Pluralsight if this course is on there
as well I guess we talked about kind of
personal mitigation techniques so what's
about corporate mitigation so what
should companies be doing so one thing
that company should do is start
identifying what information assets are
most valuable and they're marking them
accordingly so what do we mean by this
so I mean using information coding so if
you've got documents that are marked
with green okay for
lise then you kind of know that they're
okay to be in the public domain and
that's okay then you could have amber
release only before ization if you have
that on the front cover you it's an
immediate flag that okay I can't LIGO
sending this document off unless I get
permission from someone higher up in the
company right away down to red which is
confidential do not release you know
it's a very sensitive commercial
documents we should never leave the
building
but despite doing a very simple thing by
information coding all of your documents
on the front page it has becomes very
obvious what you can and can't do with
those documents so if your company
doesn't have this I mean Germany large
companies do have corporate security
policies but if you're in a smaller
company that doesn't it's a good idea to
get them written I mean they're not the
most interesting of documents granted
but it is important to have them and a
good place to start is actually on this
website here so sounds dot org as a load
of open-source templates which you can
use to kickstart your own security
policy documents but once you've written
them obviously if you just have you know
10 or 20 documents you know you can't
really expect your staff to sit down and
read them all because they won't so you
need to follow that up with suitable
training as well so I don't know how it
works in Australia but in the UK when
you have regulated financial companies
you have to have training plans in place
annually to take people through all the
key highlights of the security policies
so it's important to have these written
down because if you do have to dismiss
someone for breaking the cup the
security policy you then got that
document that you can refer back to so
as an organization you should be keeping
your software regularly pasión updated
goes without saying we will and
technically in this room it's very
important but if you don't do this and
it leads to exploits and vulnerabilities
being launched against your network so
everyone it's heard about the one
acquire virus that went around not so
long ago cause absolute chaos in the UK
especially around our National Health
Service because they hadn't passed all
of their machines so they were still
running Windows XP and old copies of
Windows XP that weren't patched up to
the latest version so it made it very
easy for that exploit to get passed
around
so going back to document shredding if
you're in a larger company then hiring
in one of those document shredding
services is very useful you know where
you get the confidential waste boxes
anything you finish we've just put them
in there if it's paper and then they get
professionally shredded and disposed of
companies are is it talking about
dumpster diving companies are a good
target for people go through the bins
just because there's an absolute
goldmine of information if you've got a
hundred members of staff and it will fry
and stuff in the bins just imagine what
information you're gonna find so this
one then so you know never assume that
your company is too small to be a target
if your company is quite small the
chances are you're more likely to be a
target you'll be easier to infiltrate so
never go on the assumption that this
isn't gonna happen to you because it
probably will okay so I said I said this
talk would be nice and easy so we've
covered most of it so in summary then so
social engineering is the act of
influence in someone's take an action
that may not be in their best interests
yeah you're trying to get people to do
something that's not good
and you're using lots of manipulation
techniques to try and do that we talks
about the different types of social
engineers that are out there ranging
from your more typical hackers your
legitimate penetration testers fruit all
these different types of people
including recruiters they're one of my
hated ones so why social engineering
again it consistently works it's very
easy to do it's you know generally
easier to try and get information out of
someone than it is to try and break into
their network people are the biggest
risk in your company so as we said
before you could be spending hundreds of
thousands of dollars on firewalls and
intrusion detection systems but all of
that which is good you shouldn't stop
doing that but your people in your
organization is still your weakest link
so having good training about how to
mitigate social engineering is very
valuable because it stops those people
doing something stupid
and again it's the path to least
resistance so if you can get someone to
give up a password he's generally are
not easier than trying to score yourself
a data breach and in trying to hack all
of the passwords are brute force all of
the passwords so we went through the the
four stages of social engineering so
information gathering pretexting which
is about taking on a persona to convince
someone that you're someone else
elicitation which is then using that
persona as a way of getting information
from people without directly asking for
it and then we looked at some different
manipulation techniques that you can use
like the fear and relief technique
footing the door technique there's many
many more so we've just covered some of
the the common ones and then we followed
up with some personal and corporate
mitigation as we've seen a lot of them
are actually kind of very obvious and
common sense things you need to do like
asking for ID for any visitors who come
in the building don't know people roam
around free in the building shredding
documents not just frying them in the
bins they're all very common-sense but
they're but they're very very important
okay so some resources which you might
want to read if you're interested in
this subject so we've got the the free
kevin Mitnick books which are
highlighted at the beginning so artur
deception and the art of intrusion both
absolutely fantastic reads you'll find
and difficult to put down when you start
reading them and then there's a ghost in
the wires which is Kevin's biography
again it's a fascinating read just
looking at some of the things you got up
to this book here is kind of considered
the Bible of social engineering the art
of human hacking it's a it's not an easy
read it's about 800 pages long but the
amount of detail that book goes into is
is absolutely fascinating if you want to
go further this one here what everybody
is saying by Joe Navarro he's an ex-fbi
interrogator and it's all about how to
read people's body language to tell if
they're lying it's a fantastic book so
if you're talking to someone and they're
sitting there rubbing their hands for
example a lot that's kind of a sign that
they're nervous or if I sit in their
steepling with their hands like that as
a sign of confidence he goes through
lots of these different techniques which
I've used in
interrogations against murderers to try
and work out they're lying or not so
fascinating hey that's it so thank you
for coming along my name is stephen
haunts and the co-founder and CTO for
small payments company new UK called
louder pay and I'm also an author on
Pluralsight so I've got a course coming
out soon which kind of covers the same
subjects of what we've been talking
about today
let's do out sometime in September and
I'm a regular speaker a lot of these
events I've done the vast majority the
NDC events now and I've spoken in
Belgium and Poland other sorts of
countries like that and also we run a
dotnet user group back in the UK called
Derbyshire net so if anyone happens to
everyone to travel to heaven a half
thousand miles to the UK and then get a
four-hour train up to a centre of the UK
and feel free to come along on the last
Thursday of every month to my user group
you'll be welcome I'll also buy you a
beer for going to that level of effort
as well so thank you very much everyone
I hope you're not made you too paranoid
and die you're not going to get a coffee
thank you
[Applause]